[Musique]
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous bach
qui m'a été bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes ancien rugbyman
professionnel l'ancien capitaine de
l'équipe nationale ivoirienne de rugby
vous avez joué au stade français à massy
à carcassonne qui a été votre dernier
club vous avez joué longtemps troisième
ligne au rugby mais au printemps 2020
vous avez été pendant un temps de ce
qu'on a appelé la première ligne mars
2020 la france entière est confiné pour
faire face à l'épidémie coville 19 on
s'en souvient tous et vous fait
embaucher comme agent d'entretien dans
un hôpital parisien c'est cet engagement
que vous racontez dans ce livre qui
s'appelle les chiffons bleus qui est
sorti au seuil est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire comment vous êtes passé des
terrains de rugby aux couloirs d'un
hôpital
un concours de circonstances où je me
retrouve confiné à paris alors que
j'habite à carcasse à je me retrouve
confiné chez j'ai ma grande soeur à
paris est quelqu'un de son entourage qui
a cherché des personnes pour pour aller
faire l'entretien justement dans un
hôpital parisien et à son fils mon neveu
donc a décidé de 10 à l'est moi je lui
ai tout simplement emboîté le pas et on
s'est retrouvés le lendemain à
travailler dans un hôpital pour faire de
l'entretien entre mars et mai 2000 vingt
six jours sur sept vous travaillez dans
cet établissement du 16ème
arrondissement qui accueille
principalement des personnes âgées votre
boulot s'est désinfecté les rampes les
téléphones les interrupteurs les
poignées de porte pas plus pas moins non
tous les jours la même chose des
horaires fixes le même circuit les mêmes
objets tous les jours une routine assez
particulière est assez assez fatigantes
reçoit le chiffon bleu le nom du livre
ce sont ces petites serpillière qui
finissent par vous obséder vous raconter
que les premiers jours vous êtes épuisé
on est premiers jours je me rend compte
très vite de l'ampleur de la tâche mais
mais je suis heureux d'être là je suis
heureux de pouvoir contribuer à aider
dans cet hôpital parce que la tâche que
je fais elle était souvent elle avait
souvent été faite par départ des
soignants je me disais que tant qu'à
faire autant qu'il soit prêt dès auprès
des patients auprès des malades et puis
et puis voilà en première ligne mais
absolument imperceptible je devins
simple nettoyeur de l'infime sommes
désormais invisible ou presque militant
de cette discrète armée des ombres dans
la dont la principale fonction était de
ne laisser aucune trace de son ouvrage
passer de la lumière du rugby ah ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai je dénotait un
petit peu par rapport à ma carrure parce
que il et les gens n'étaient pas
habitués à avoir quelqu'un d'aussi
grands mais pour le reste je disais
bonjour je dirai au revoir mais je
faisais gt gt concentrer sur ma tâche
est et jusqu'à la
l'emballement médiatique qui a eu les
gens ne connaissaient pas ne me
reconnaissez pas et c'était très bien
comme ça mais on va y revenir dans un
instant mais on va rappeler quand même
que l'hôpital à ce moment là en france
via un moment très particulier
vous êtes au plus près d'ailleurs et
vous en témoigner dans ce livre de
l'engagement des soignants qui sont à ce
moment là au début de ce confinement
largement qu'ils le sont encore
d'ailleurs mais en sous-effectif et qui
sont sous-équipés vous raconter que
voilà il n'y a pas de blouse ya
quasiment pas de masque c'est ça on a un
pénurie de matériel et on en parlait à
la télé j'ai pu j'ai pu le toucher du
doigt effectivement ou où les soignants
sont obligés de réutiliser des sur blues
à chaque fois les masques sont comptés
distribué au compte gouttes justement et
et c'est vrai que c'est étonnant pour un
pays comme la france une puissance
économique mondiale se retrouver
avec un service public qui est aux abois
vous êtes interrogé sur le bien fondé de
votre démarche d'autant plus vous lisiez
à l'instant qu'elle a été assez vite et
presque malgré vous très médiatisée au
point que vous êtes trouvé dans une
situation parfois un peu confortable oui
oui c'est vrai que je pensais que ça
allait rester confiné à la sphère rugby
et je me suis dit voilà on va en parler
un peu dans la rubrique sport je
m'attendais pas à ce que ça soit repris
par des par les médias nationaux partout
les par la presse régionale par toutes
les matinales des radios et au début je
me prêtaient volontiers à l'exercice en
me disant qu' on pourrait parler de ces
gens là qui eux ont pas attendu le coc
vide la crue du coc vite pour pour faire
ce travail là pour faire ce métier là
les soignants et les agents d'entretien
il ya une complicité très forte entre
eux et c'est ce que je raconte
dans le livre notamment et au bout d'un
moment j'ai dit j'ai dit stop aux
sollicitations médiatiques parce que je
me suis rendu compte qu'on cherchait à
voir l'histoire d'un joueur de rugby qui
faisait le ménage et moi c'était pas ça
que j'avais envie de raconter et
d'ailleurs si vous dans ce livre ce que
vous racontez avant avant votre propre
expérience et effectivement cette petite
société qui s'est créé dans ce temps
suspendu
magnifique entre les soignants les
agents d'entretien les patients bien sûr
la laddh que convoi au détour d'une
porte qui s'ouvre d'un couloir c'est ça
que vous avez voulu raconter oui j'étais
un invité privilégié dans ce dans ce
petit monde et j'ai observé j'ai laissé
traîner les oreilles je regardais
j'étais en mode éponge absorber tout ce
qu'il y avait autour de moi et j'ai
tenté de le retranscrire dans ce livre
l'un dès le premier jour quand tu
rentrais le soir j'étais effectivement
fatigué mais j'avais pris des notes sans
vraiment savoir ce que j'allais en faire
et et ses notes au fur et à mesure se
sont transformés en ce livre il ya un
observateur particulier de ce qui vous
est arrivé notamment à part ces moments
où vous êtes vous avez été médiatisée
c'est votre maman qui a fait semblant de
ne pas être fiers de votre démarche
salle de là d'autant plus touché que
elle même a été femme de ménage pendant
des années oui
elle a d'abord exprimé de la peur ce qui
semblait logique je venais de rentrer de
l'étranger elle était inquiète que je ne
puisse pas rentrer
j'étais blessé en plus au genou et deux
jours après je me retrouve à travailler
dans un hôpital en plein coït donc elle
a eu peur pour son fils ce que je peux
comprendre puis au final elle était oui
elle était plutôt fier de ce que je
faisais sans en rajouter et elle aussi a
été surprise par le par le bruit que ça
a fait parce que ça découle est plus de
l'éducation qu'elle nous a donné que
qu'autres choses donc elle n'était pas
surprise elle mais elle était plutôt
fier vous rappeler dans ce livre que
votre sort avoue était sans doute
meilleurs que ceux des gens que vous
avez croisé vous n'êtes restait que je
dise avec des guillemets que quelques
mois vous n'avez jamais et toucher
l'argent de votre paye deux ans plus
tard quasiment jour pour jour après le
début de ce premier confinement on parle
moins voire jamais plus de ce qu'on a
pourtant applaudi pendant tant que
semaine c'est ça on n'en parle plus et
pourtant si - sont bien présents dans ma
vie puisque je reste en contact avec eux
je communique avec eux régulièrement je
passe les voir de temps en temps quand
tu rends de passage de passage sur paris
mais c'est vrai qu'il se retroune
retourner dans un anonymat le plus le
plus complet au même titre que les
soignants qu'on applaudissait à 20
heures tous les soirs comment
l'expliquer
ça fait partie de comme je vous dis j'ai
coutume de dire qu'on n'a pas idée
d'arriver dans un hôpital qui est sale
c'est un acquis pour nous de te dire que
l'hôpital doit être un lieu propre que
l'hôpital que le service public doit
être irréprochable sans se soucier des
moyens ou des who dès qu'on leur donne
donc c'est acquis dans les consciences
la conscience collective et donc de fait
les médias ont leur rôle à jouer puisque
dans cette période kobe dont parlait
énormément de covile il fallait bien
trouver des sujets donc il fallait
parler de ces acteurs là aujourd'hui le
comité est passé dans un second plan on
l'espère pour
longtemps et du coup forcément dont on
parle moins de ces gens là se sont donc
à toutes ces petites mains anonymes que
vous avez pensé lors de votre dernier
match de carrière de pro c'était en mai
dernier à carcassonne le livre il est
pour eux oui clairement clairement et
j'étais j'ai vraiment j'ai pas encore eu
l'occasion d'aller leur présenter mais
j'ai vraiment hâte d'aller leur
présenter non ils n'ont pas vu ils le
savent vous en avez parlé et j'ai
vraiment hâte de leur présenter et de
pouvoir leur dire que ben ce livre la
cce quoi plus que moi c'est vraiment eu
et je voulais dépeindre tous et toutes
ces personnes qui sont devenus des
personnages mais qui sont avant tout des
personnes et vous à titre personnel il
reste quoi pour vous de ces chiffons
bleus
comme vous le disais tout à l'heure
c'était une parenthèse suspendu un peu
un peu magique pendant laquelle j'ai été
et c'est mon dernier match de rugby où
didier aussi j'ai pensé j'avais une
pensée et une pensée profonde pour eux
et je pourrai jamais m'en défaire de ça
et je le garde j'ai voulu leur a conté
et forcément ça a changé ma vie oui
quelques mots peut-être de l'avenir vous
avez raccroché les crampons en mai
dernier c'est fini fini
c'est fini fini j'avais l'opportunité de
pouvoir continuer pour tenter de
qualifier la côte d'ivoire à la coupe du
monde 2023 en france j'ai décidé
d'arrêter et j'ai décidé aussi de leur
prêter main forte d'une autre manière en
enfilant un coup de main au staff et en
essayant de transmettre tout ce que le
rugby m'a donné aux joueurs qui eux vont
représenter les couleurs de la côte
d'ivoire et je suis à fond derrière eux
et même si je suis plus sur les terrains
je reste
le premier supporters du rugby ivoirien
du rugby ivoirien a duré deux meilleurs
français j'imagine aussi les derniers
jours ont été plutôt chaud au coeur oui
le week end dernier et était vraiment
fort en émotions on a on a la sensation
d'une équipe de france qui car où
trouver son lustre d'antan et qui
presque quasiment imbattable et de les
voir à ce niveau là on a presque eu peur
d'eux qu'ils soient prêts trop tôt on a
envie qu'il soit qui garde cette forme
optimale jusqu'à la coupe du monde 2023
et je pense que il n'y aura pas plus
belle fête que si antoine dupin le
capitaine soulève la coupe du monde au
stade de france bah ils nous ont fait du
bien en tout cas à ces bleus dans ce
contexte un peu compliqué merci beaucoup
c'est un livre extrêmement touchant et
très bien et très bien écrit baky emma
était que j'ai lu avec plaisir un très
beau témoignage qui est donc paru au
seuil les chiffons bleus voilà on l'a vu
à l'antenne merci beaucoup lorsque nous
en parlait ce matin à bientôt